ich weiß ja nicht wie es ihnen geht aber
ich komme langsam nicht mehr mit
wirklich jetzt liefert deutschland also
doch schwere waffen an die ukraine
eine zeitenwende jagte die nächste nur
der wahnsinn wahnsinn die zeiten werden
geben sich quasi die klinke in die hand
demnächst also wirklich in wenigen
wochen maximal monaten schicken wir den
ukrainern gut abgehangene gebhard panzer
dabei handelt es sich zumindest vom
gewicht her eindeutig um schwere waffen
also das schlimme wort dass olaf scholz
wochenlang nicht sagen wollte geht es um
erhebliche
waffen mit erhebliche auswirkungen
[Applaus]
sagt der mann mit den erheblichen
wortfindungsstörungen
gestern hat der bundestag in einem
gemeinsamen antrag von union und ampel
gefordert schwere waffen zu liefern
wir erinnern uns vorher vorher hatten
sich regierung und opposition
gegenseitig vorgeworfen in der waffen
frage der reine parteipolitik zu
bezahlen und das ulkige ist beide hatten
recht wir wollen hier auch keine
parteitaktischen spiele machen
parteipolitische spielchen taktischen
spielchen taktische spielchen
parteipolitischen klamm augen
parteipolitisches boden turnen
gut zur wahrheit gehört andere eu und
nato partner machen in wirklichkeit viel
weniger als deutschland ist woran die
ampel aber tatsächlich arbeiten muss und
zwar schnell ist ihre kommunikation erst
heißt es wir haben keine waffen
abzugeben dann beim sogenannten
ringtausch aber plötzlich doch dann
wollten wir möglichst keinen dritten
weltkrieg auslösen nachvollziehbar und
jetzt liefern wir trotzdem flach panzer
kurz gesagt
tatsächlich hat es olaf scholz damit
sogar in den duden geschafft wirklich
gucken sie mal wo ist es hier scholzen
ultra schwaches färbt
sich komplett widersprechen das super
komplizierte ausreden sinnlos
aneinanderreihen siehe auch er hat mich
angeschaut
und da hat jemand aber ordentlich holz
gebaut
gut jetzt ausdrücklich nichts gegen
besonnenheit ist eine ganz wichtige
eigenschaft in so einer krise klar aber
ein bundeskanzler hat halt schon die
berühmte
richtlinienkompetenz das ist klare zur
not auch unpopuläre entscheidungen
treffen und jetzt kommt's kommunizieren
ist nicht sein ding hier neues
kinderbuch kennen sie das schon ganz
toll ich habe ein freund der es
eigentlich kanzler aber manchmal merkt
man es nicht er heißt olaf oft sitzt an
seinem schreibtisch schon fragt sich ob
ans telefon gehen soll wenn schon wieder
der ukrainische botschafter anruft ich
warte man denkt oh ja vielleicht hört ja
gleich auf jeden morgen steht da eine
stunde vorm schrank und überlegt ob er
den tauben grauen oder doch den stein
grauen anzug tragen sind auch mittags in
der kantine grübelt olaf lange ketchup
oder mayo auf die pommes oder beides die
zeit nimmt er sich und es ist ihnen egal
ob die kollegen das dorf hin und morgen
lese ich aus ich habe ein freund der ist
altkanzler trinken rotwein und geplant
uwe interviews
ja
nicht besonders kindgerecht aber schön
so herr scholz drückt sich kryptisch aus
wohl auch aus rücksicht auf teile seiner
partei aber tauschen möchte man mit dem
man weiß gott nicht putin hat gerade
polen und bulgarien den gashahn
zugedreht jetzt fragt man sich natürlich
auch bei uns droht bald der
freedom day ja ja ich finde ja gerade
bei dem thema müssten wir aufhören
signale der schwäche zu senden öl
embargo jetzt und am besten verkündete
eu auch eine preisobergrenze für
russisches gas warum er nicht hat der
italienische ministerpräsident tragen
gerade genauso vorgeschlagen und traten
sie doch mal wer da schon wieder bremst
war eine rhetorische frage
früher oder später müssen wir doch
sowieso runter von dem stoff wir haben
auf der einen seite die abhängigkeit von
russland in der tat schon reduziert von
35 auf 35 prozent
ja das geht doch schon mal in die
richtige richtung oder
noch hat putin keine gasleitung nach
china das heißt jetzt können wir ihnen
noch treffen mit einem embargo ohne
verhandlungen wird sich auch dieser
konflikt am ende nicht lösen lassen aber
solange in der ukraine putins
systematischer terror gegen die
bevölkerung weiter geht muss man denen
natürlich helfen sich zu verteidigen zum
beispiel mit sagen wir mal gut
erhaltenen deutschen gebraucht waffen ja
ist ja so wie
die
wie zum beispiel mit diesen 50 gepard
panzern das war eine sehr spontane
entscheidung am dienstag verkündet und
der ukrainische botschafter hat sich
doch bestimmt tierisch gefreut oder der
ukrainische botschafter wenig zweifelt
offen am nutzen der die gute botschaft
nur es gibt keine munition twittert er
ach so sie wollten panzer mit munition
ja sowas haben wir nicht entschuldigung
leider können wir tatsächlich dürfen die
geparden nicht mit ihrer in der
neutralen schweiz hergestellten munition
ausgeliefert werden deswegen fangen wir
jetzt an unter anderem in brasilien nach
antiken patronen zu graben das hätte man
vor wochen machen können und müssen und
der gepard ist ja nicht unser einziges
problem tier ja da sind ja auch noch
diese 100 ausgemusterten marder panzer
und
88 leoparden die seit anno dunnemals
beim hersteller rheinmetall auf dem hof
vor sich hin rosten
rheinmetall abteilung schwere waffen was
ein leopard wir sind doch kein zoo auch
die panzer da muss ich mal gucken
der stolz kauft uns unsere
unternehmen als rückspiegel fall tabu
team von hinten angreift
die kauflust der ganze scheiß ab ich
fass es nicht
das hat mein alter opel astra das
merkten die dorf wir brauchen dich
gedient rheinmetall hat bei rudolf
alte häuser
sind also plötzlich ein neuer markt
hätte das gedacht wir schalten wir live
zum rüstungskonzern krauss maffei
wegmann nach münchen dort leidet claus
von wagner die abteilung
gebrauchtfahrzeuge höher herr von wagner
wie hilfreich ist der gepard ein gerät
aus den späten 60ern
der ecke sie sind doch selbst ein gerät
spaß beiseite er sie wirklich auf den
keeper lasse ich gar nichts kommt das
ist ein top fahrzeug der hat alles yacht
130 ps in der spitze 65 stück ist zwei
maschinen kann nun 35 millimeter liegt
auf der straße wie ein brett und
ledersitze
japan das einzige was nicht in kiel wäre
das wäre die tankfüllung also müssen sie
mich ja auch verstehen bei den
dieselpreisen dann müsste ich erst die
niere meiner frau verkaufen
und das habe ich schon
gesagt er wäre das teil ist der hammer
wirksamer schutz bereich bis 3500
besucher da es erfasst feindliche
flugziele ab 15 km entfernung
und er kann rtl 2 empfangen
wenn der wind richtig steht
meint es ist unfassbar dass die
bundeswehr den gepard vor zehn jahren
ausgemustert hat mit der bürger wisse
was die begründung wozu brauchen wir in
die flugabwehr doch es soll uns denn
angreifen der russe
da kann man heute womöglich nur an herrn
putins fernis appellieren uns nicht aus
der luft anzugreifen
das wäre nämlich extrem unsportlich ja
verstehen aber hilft der gepard in der
ukraine und vor allem ist er
einigermaßen leicht zu bedienen da ja
wirklich ein ein
vorangehen muss noch eine sehr intensive
und damit noch länger anhaltende
ausbildung also ich würde sie mit
monaten beziffert monate monaten monate
monate nur damit ich das richtig
verstehe ja wer noch fehlenden ukraine
an erst den marder könnten nicht haben
der ist zu kompliziert für euch und
jetzt liefern wir ihnen einen noch viel
komplizierteren panzer den wir damals
und ich zitiere wörtlich wegen zu hohem
wartungs und ausbildungsaufgaben selber
nicht mehr haben wollten hat das ist ja
alles richtig aber man kann das erklären
unsere verteilung ist müsst ihr in die
frau allerhand prächtig konnte am
dienstag schlecht mit leeren händen zum
gipfel nach ramstein kommen wenn du
irgendwo eingeladen bist dann musst du
etwas mitbringen und sie kann halt nicht
backen
ehrlich unter uns hier planen kuchen
verstößt gegen die genfer konvention und
da hat sie kurz gegoogelt und unsere
anzeige bei panzer scout24 gesehen 50
gebhard flaig panzer ideal für bastler
top-zustand nur zehn jahre im hof von
tauben volk schießen
in schulter warum sie es gar nicht so
vorwurf so schauen herreweghe
deutschland muss eben auch mal liefern
statt sich immer nur vor den verbündeten
zu blamieren ja leider unvergessen das
betrifft vor allem die mission am horn
von afrika wichtig ist aber zu wissen
wir sind dort nicht alleine sondern mit
anderen partnern die hubschrauber haben
die fliegen
das kennen wir nicht mehr deutscher
hubschrauber ganz viel schraub leider
kein hub
alter pilot mit da lob ich mir doch eher
welche den oldie but goldie es gibt
aktuell noch nicht mal munition die wir
mit liefern könnten das stimmt aber wie
heißt es so schön in meiner branche
gekauft wie gesehen
er werde jetzt bewahrheitet sich endlich
was meine großmutter immer gesagt hat
klaus hat sie gesagt nie etwas
wegschmeißen hier das verkaufen willst
der bundeswehr als nächstes das ist das
g37 ein schuss pro minute schuss
reichweite etwa drei meter 70
herzlichen glückwunsch von magna und
herren
ja
der gepard
man könnte fast meinen die ampel hat
sich gefragt mit welchem waffensystem
machen wir putin am wenigsten wütend so
jetzt aber mal eine ganz andere frage
auch wichtig wohin mit opa
also jetzt nicht nein nicht das einen
beim gerd noch irgendwas schocken könnte
aber das interview in der new york times
schießt wirklich den vogel ab er
verteidigt seinen kumpel putin eisern
weiter eisern ist tragisch ich finds
fragen schuldig inzwischen sagen sogar
die hells angels hannover sie wollen
nicht mehr mit schröder gesehen werden
ist eben sein bild in der geschichte
eigentlich völlig egal was soll denn
hängen bleiben für euch zu sehen
widersprüche bundes
deutschland von 1900
und dann hatte ich keinen bock mehr zu
arbeiten und habe mir einen reichen
russen geangelt
wollen auch sie mich mieten rufen sie
jetzt an
in der eu diskutieren sie schon über
sanktionen gegen schröder ja wirklich
ich fürchte allerdings keine sanktionen
der welt könnte den noch zum einlenken
bewegen diesen verbohrten alten mann
hier schröder im dezember 2021 plötzlich
schwerhörig und da stehen sie auch zu
eine persönliche freundschaft zum
russischen präsidenten pflegen aber
dennoch die frage weil sie vielleicht
besonders gut einschätzen können kann so
einer situation kommen wo sie dann in
einen loyalitätskonflikt peter hier kann
es zu einer situation kommen wo sie zu
einem in einen loyalitätskonflikt
dichter fragen
was
wo bin ich
er versteht wirklich die frage nicht
also inhaltlich und da waren zu dem
zeitpunkt waren die russischen truppen
schon an der grenze schröder tut bis
heute so als stünde seine russland
politik quasi in der tradition von willy
brandt auf denen sich neuerdings ja auch
manuela schwesig beruft ich hab gehört
der willy brandt statue in der berliner
spd-zentrale ist das so peinlich die hat
offiziell gekündigt
nachvollziehbar und herz schröder der
paria der deutschen politik und wir
schalten mal live nach hannover zu
unserem reporter ulrich von heesen
ulrich kriegt der altkanzler überhaupt
noch besuch seit dem new york times
interview
der mann ist völlig isoliert hierbei den
schröder kims klingeln eigentlich nur
noch die zeugen jehovas nachbarn die
sich über den zigarren gestank beschwert
und natürlich der lieferdienste von
chance wein depot oder ist ja sie müssen
zum linken eingang da
jetzt kommt auch noch der lieferdienste
von pierce bodo bode
jaha na klar muss für das ganze
wochenende reicht ja
aber mal bei allen berechtigten schröder
bashing vielleicht müssen wir uns auch
mal als gesellschaft tragen was sagt das
über uns wenn ein 78-jähriger immer noch
arbeiten muss in russischen
aufsichtsräten weil er sonst in
grundsicherung fällt verdammt der agenda
manchmal
na ja
man müsste mal raus man müsste mal
rauskriegen verdi eingeführt hat ja das
müssen wir mal sie wollen aber nicht
wirklich gerd schröder in schutz nehmen
oder nein
gerd schröder ist unser aller peinlicher
onkel
seine eigene partei schämt sich für ihn
aber ihm ist es scheiße ja wer will
schon von der partei geliebt werden also
mehr reicht meine frau
ja welche jetzt
klar klar hat sich der mann kaufen
lassen wieso ist irgendwie überrascht
wenn er den kriegsverbrecher in schutz
nimmt dafür wird er bezahlt das ist
seine arbeit ansonsten ist gerd schröder
das was er immer war ein riesen fan von
gerd schröer
gerhard schröder sitzend unter einem
gemälde von sich selbst gibt der new
york times ein interview
ich mache jetzt nicht einen auf mea
culpa dass es nicht mein ding also
kommen
also das ist schon ein geiler satz oder
habe ich mir direkt als t shirt druck
lassen
der körper ist nicht mein ding
das so raus zu hauen ist schon ein
ziemlicher post vor allem in einem land
wo sich alle den ganzen tag nur noch
entschuldigt also sorry komplimente für
putins gekauften cheflobbyisten das
fällt mir wurde erzählt sie haben neuen
porsche stimmt das eigentlich
und
was hat das jetzt mit irgendetwas zu tun
beeinträchtigt dass meine arbeit als
journalist oder wie
hier geht nur die heuchelei auf den
geist wir haben uns doch alle gefreut
über das billige ganz die ganze spd hat
sich dafür auf dem rücken gelegt und
verkauft das jetzt im nachhinein als
friedenspolitik und nicht nur die spd
jede menge politiker sind gerade super
dankbar dass alle nur über gerhard
schröder schimpfen
guckt da will sie schon wieder eine
bedanken
apa
warte mal irgendwoher kenne ich die
stimmt da klingelt was ich komme nicht
darauf eure ich von heesen vielen dank
hallo leute ich bin der heute-show
[Musik]
hersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß
und liegt - wollt dann abonniert jetzt
den kanal
was zur hölle ist mine der stelle
[Musik]